[Music]
oh baby new parents rihanna and asap
rocky are impossibly stylish on their
italian date night i'm trying to enjoy
it as much as i could the couple who
welcomed their son back in may held
hands making their way out of nyc
hotspot carbone over the weekend their
fits always on point reese rocking an
all black look a corset under a long
trench with pants pumps and a matching
dior purse meanwhile rocky's sporting a
dark blue coordinated set a jacket and
t-shirt with shorts to match the
ensembles paired perfectly with chic
shades i had to make it work but this
isn't the first time re and rocky have
been out and about since their son's
arrival the singer showed up to support
her beau during his set at lollapalooza
in paris last week re-kept it comfy for
the festival with a track suit but
brought the fashon accessorizing with
chunky jewelry i
love what i love and prior to that
outing the two were spotted at a barber
shop in london
[Music]
how is this happening right now
fans were in disbelief seeing rocky
getting his haircut with re by his side
the grammy winner even taking time to
snap pics with the locals
the longtime pals who started dating in
2020 revealed they were expecting their
first child together back in january and
with that came a whole lot of excitement
what are you looking forward to as you
move into a new chapter of your life i'm
just excited for what i don't know yet
you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited and when the baby
came in may a source told eet that the
rapper still felt the same way and is
looking forward to raising their baby
boy together quote before rihanna gave
birth asap was super involved and was
asking his friends for parenting advice
he wants to be the best dad possible and
continue to take care of rihanna it's
amazing and i'm honestly truly blessed
real you know and as a couple our source
says asap and rihanna are down to earth
have similar styles and couldn't be more
in love and happy about this next
chapter she may never wear it but she
save it so our babies will be flyer than
their parents so now that the little one
is here what does that mean for
rihanna's other baby her music you're
still gonna get music from me maybe a
lullaby i can see you and asap dropping
demos in the studio oh my goodness not a
lullaby my fans would kill me they
waited this long for a lullaby letting
us sleep with this music we are grown
[Music]
you